the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
remember this former sheriff you
probably remember what when he was a
sheriff many of you may not have
realized he's no longer a sheriff joe
arpaio known for his insanely aggressive
and inhumane treatment of prisoners in
his jail as well as general racist
activity as it relates to arizona's show
us your papers provisions and statutes
he was convicted of a criminal charge
earlier this week for refusing to stop
traffic patrols that were specifically
targeting immigrants which was sort of
like the final rebuke of Joe Arpaio he
was at one point really popular the
crackdowns were popular with the so
called Law & Order crowd and he was even
considered sort of a political player
where were when candidates would visit
Arizona they would meet with Jill Arpaio
and it was like you get the stamp of
approval from Joe Arpaio what does Joe
Arpaio think about you Donald Trump was
so proud to have his endorsement and now
the guy has been convicted of a crime
and he was found guilty of misdemeanor
contempt of court for ignoring a court
order back from 2011 to stop these
immigrant targeting patrols he's 85
years old faces up to six years in jail
although attorneys who have been
following the case say it's unlikely
that an eighty five-year-old convicted
of a misdemeanor is going to end up
incarcerated which is too bad honestly
especially if you consider the treatment
that he had these detainees go through I
mean he would set them up in camps
outside and have them deal with 100-plus
degree heat out in Arizona he made them
wear pink underwear split up families I
mean I don't know if you can you know
get the guy's 85 and I understand like
when you're sentencing him I don't think
those things are in consideration
especially because they're not relevant
to the K correct but I think he would
deserve it you wouldn't feel bad it not
me ended up incarcerated he actually
there were two prior criminal
investigations into Sheriff
joe arpaio but he was and he avoided any
legal problems there but ultimately the
continued signature imagine that this is
what you're known for his signature
immigration patrols which are in
violation of the law by the way that's
what he's known for
and they racially profiled Latinos and
that's that and he violated the order so
that he could continue trying to boost
his 2012 reelection campaign is actually
why he did it in other words were it not
for trying to get reelected as sheriff
in 2012 he might have followed the 2011
order and said fine I've been told not
to do this I'm not going to do it and
just the entire thing imploding and I
think his loss may have to do with the
demographics changing too I mean good
luck getting the Hispanic vote there
yeah I think it's also point to the
hypocrisy of right-wingers when it comes
to law and order because that doesn't
necessarily just mean toughness right
right I mean how crack how much you
crack down on these immigrant
populations doesn't mean that you're you
know some sort of Law & Order hero not
only they have to actually follow the
law and yet what he was doing the other
day I was going to say which is you
can't defend not following the law
because you're trying to sort of uphold
some higher order other virtue as you
determined it or something like that up
to you a think oh here it's not up to
you that law and order it's a violation
of the separation of powers the chain of
command all the stuff that conservatives
sometimes say that they're all for yeah
absolutely
one thing that Donald Trump often says
he's for although it's clear whether he
has any knowledge of it whatsoever is
the Bible yeah and there's a report
which says that some members of Donald
Trump's cabinet attend a weekly Bible
study session CBN News which is the
Christian Broadcasting Network they are
reporting that once a week about a dozen
members of trumps cabinet gather to
study Scripture together Betsy DeVos is
reportedly a regular the Agriculture
Secretary sonny Perdue shows up Rick
Perry energy secretary shows up CIA
director Mike Pompeo Attorney General
Jeff session a lot of fun it's quite a
quite a motley crew now I honestly don't
know whether this is true because
anything that originates with the
Christian Broadcasting Network I'm
skeptical of but at the same time they
are the place that would love to paint
Trump as this Bible following great
moral guide despite you know the grabbin
by the [ __ ] tapes the multiple divorces
the indiscriminate willingness seemingly
to kill people abroad if it suits his
political agenda or will distract from
scandals yeah but he's the moral guy and
CBN loves pushing that and I guess some
of his cabinet meets and they pray and
learn Scripture
I think this opens up an interesting
conversation about the First Amendment
because obviously if these cabinet
members are on the clock and having this
Bible study on government grounds like
at the White House yeah there would be a
clear violation of separation of church
and state well I don't know
well isn't in the First Amendment I mean
you know we have the Treaty of Tripoli
and Jefferson wrote extensively about
this but you know as long as it's off
the clock and they're outside of
government property then they also have
their own freedom of association yeah
their own freedom of religion is that
simple I'm not and here's why so school
sanctioned prayer right it's abundantly
clear that there can be no this is the
time for prayer in a public school can't
have that however if there are areas
that are rest areas or recess areas or
as far as the teachers are concerned
maybe like a teacher's lounge if
teachers decide they want to gather and
have a prayer session during a break or
whatever the case may be or if students
want to go to the library and pray that
I believe is okay because it is not
school sanctioned so how long this is
taking place after hours - we'll get on
the weekend that's my next thing when
you're in the cabinet you're not
punching a clock I don't think there is
a thing's after hours and there's no
thing as being on the clock or being off
the clock so I think that that makes it
complex and the same location thing
applies even if they're doing it
wherever at the win the west wing or
whatever the case may be it I don't know
how you demonstrate that this violates
the law like embrace Italy I get what
you're saying but I think if they say
hey let's get together and chat let's
get together and read the Bible let's
get together and
pray these are pretty blurry areas
legally speaking yeah it's interesting
because if you work for the government
whether that the local state or federal
you are the government so that's why you
know teachers can't have Bible study in
front of their classrooms right and it's
much more clear when a teacher is off
work because obviously the summers off
you have the weekends for direct work
lock yeah
but you know if you think about a job
where the employees are working around
the clock all the time if one's where
you're in charge of entire departments
in the executive branch
yeah very hard to point out what the
limit of it is but in any case if you
like our elected officials or I guess
our cabinet they're not elected but
appointed by the person that was elected
the president if you like them spending
time learning about Bible stories then I
guess that this would make you happy I
don't know I guess that's incredibly
concerning to I mean you know they don't
have to be entirely in contradiction
with what they're doing at their jobs
but you'd have to imagine they often are
especially when you have like Betsy
DeVos going to these and you know I
don't know how fundamentalist she is but
maybe she doesn't believe in evolution
maybe she thinks that the world was
created 6,000 years ago that's going to
affect her work or people working in
energy or environment or whatever and
don't think that climate change is a
real thing or you believe is coming or
or even just as simple as like you don't
believe that God would create a planet
that humans could damage yes who cares
about climate change who cares about
pollution here's one evidence and
there's right a bit
honestly change your mind because you
know endless ways that literal Bible
belief and it's not just I mean it
happens to be that these are all
Christians but it could be any religious
text
there are infinite ways in which
religious texts could directly conflict
with or influence how you behave as a
civil servant I take it there's no
Muslims and Trump's cabinet no but I'm
sure there's some some Muslims that work
at the White House right yeah
there must be okay Jared Kushner the
golden boy he was going to be the guy to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
he was going to fix it Trump was going
to send him over there and he was going
to fix the entire thing we have now
learned due to a recording that was
taken at an event where Jared Kushner
spoke
Recordings were not supposed to have
been made but somebody made a recording
anyway and in this recording Jared
Kushner sort of conceded it might not be
possible to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict you're
telling me that the guy that Donald
Trump identified as the best possible
person to single-handedly go over to the
Middle East and solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict he's
conceding it may not be solvable there
and there's two ways to look at this
view either you see this and you say oh
this confirms Jared Kushner is actually
not knowledgeable about this issue and
is not a good person to be negotiating
israeli-palestinian peace or if you
believe that he really is the best
person to do it and he says it's not
solvable you might say it's not solvable
I mean Jimmy you might consider this the
word of the deity I don't know whatever
if Kushner says it can't be solved then
it can't be solved we might as well stop
trying I mean it seems as if he's
arriving this route to this conclusion
after having worked on the issue for six
months and maybe he'd have this like
very detailed nuanced opinion but
judging from the audio that leaked that
doesn't seem to be the case now seems to
be throwing up his hands in the air
because well Israel wants this and
Palestine wants this I mean how could we
possibly reconcile those two positions
it's like what you would think if you
had had a five-minute brief explanation
of some aspect of the
israeli-palestinian conflict trying to
sum up the last seventy and even more
years of this conflict this issue and
you come away saying hey I learned that
each side kind of has different
priorities and different things that
they want and it just might be to me
about the problem I mean it's not like
it's a well calculated expert now you
know regardless of if they have an
inclination decide with one group or the
other group saying well I've studied
this for ten twenty years and you know I
it's going to be a tough thing to solve
I don't know if we can solve it but this
is how we would do it is the first
answer yes you step so you like
providing any of that stuff
it's absolutely pathetic and and again
the narrative Trump I'll put the best
people around me I know who the best
people are I'm going to build the best
team they're going to do great the guy
that was going to be the savior on the
Israeli
Palestinian conflict saying might not be
solvable just might not be able to do it
at all yeah and then I remember I think
early on in Trump's presidency he had
the Palestinian president visit the
White House Abbas Mohammed Allah well
yes the oh he's in charge of the West
Bank okay so they were thinking you know
maybe Trump's open to his two-state
solution maybe if anyone's going to be
committed to helping us solve peace in
the Middle East it's going to be the
Trump administration I think Jared
Kushner saying this and just kind of
giving up after six months just shows
that they're going to throw their hands
up in the air and move on to another
issue oh yeah that's the thing I'm just
more honest you move on when you can't
fix something you just move on in the
Trump administration blame Democrats or
Obama or low-energy Republicans or
whoever it's did a boss visit the White
House I didn't know that so yes oh okay
that's it for today's bonus show thanks
for watching thanks for listening thanks
for joining me the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]